I want to welcome you to the first women
in management speaker series our
headline event we are really pleased to
have Heidi Roizen with us today before
we get started I'd like to go over a few
logistics I'm going to do a quick
introduction and then turn it over to
Margo Langsdorff who is the president of
women in management she's going to do a
fireside chat after the formal Q&A we'll
turn it over to you if you have a
question you'd like to pull it posed
please raise your hand and much like a
view from the top we'll pass you a
microphone and with that I think we're
gonna begin Heidi Roizen has spent her
life immersed in the Silicon Valley
ecosystem as an entrepreneur corporate
executive venture capitalist and member
of several boards after receiving her
undergraduate and MBA degrees from
Stanford University Heidi co-founded
team maker company an early personal
computer software company in 1983 she
served as the CEO from inception through
its acquisition by deluxe corporation in
1994 in 1996
Heidi joined Apple as vice president of
worldwide developer relations from there
Heidi entered the venture capital world
serving as managing managing director of
Mobius venture capital from 1999 to 2007
today Heidi splits her time between her
entrepreneurial endeavor skinny songs
and board service in the public private
and nonprofit sectors in 2008 Hadiya was
named the annual Achievement Award
winner by the forum for women
entrepreneurs and executives she is
married and has two children with that
I'd like to turn it over to Margo and I
please ask that you help me in joining
Erin join me in welcoming Heidi
Hidy on behalf of women and management
and the entire GSB community we're
thrilled to have you here so thank you
so much so in the latest evolution of
your career how do you feel your network
continues to play a role in your
personal success and development two
very different halves to my career
skinny songs that is you know it's a
crazy idea that I came up with this very
entrepreneurial I really decided to
throw myself a dad and learn about the
music industry and create this album of
music and I I don't play an instrument I
don't sing I can't read music so I was
really not very well qualified for that
job but I was passionate about the idea
I was passionate about what I wanted to
get across from a lyrics perspective and
so then I had to do what you typically
do in an entrepreneur and you have a
great idea but you're not the one who
can execute you go find people much
better than you are you talk them into
the idea and you get them to come along
with it
so in that case networking was really
interesting because my network was not
I don't like hang with a Nashville so
for me it was figuring out who did I
know who knew somebody who knew somebody
and then how could I get the pitch done
and how could I use my credibility in
the valley to translate somewhere else
now I will say I had one tremendous
advantage that most people in the music
business don't have is a I could fund
the project myself although I couldn't
hey everybody the full kind of salaries
that they get paid to do this but I had
enough money that if I could convince
them to do it for royalties I could I
could get it off the ground and be I did
not need to make a living in the music
industry because trust me
well if that's your plan have a have a
back-up plan cuz
the music industry is kind of not
exactly a great place to make money and
so so I kind of knew that to be the case
but I felt that this was something that
I could get to sustainability and
profitability and I really wanted to try
it out so in that case my network was
was valuable in some ways in some ways
obviously there aren't you know there
were there are no connections and the
other thing that's interesting is
contextually everyone will take your
calls when you're a venture capitalist
and you're in Silicon Valley and you
have hot startups and and they're and
they want to raise money from you when
you're hawking a musical product and you
call up the vice president at Weight
Watchers because you've figured out who
they are on LinkedIn and you have a
friend three levels removed they aren't
necessarily that's like to take your
call so one of the interesting things
that that I discovered is that you know
credibility and power doesn't
necessarily translate into a different
world and you have to be ready to kind
of start from scratch and and really do
this stuff over and over again although
one of the funniest things and actually
it relates to Weight Watchers at Weight
Watchers com the guy who ran sort of the
Weight Watchers com web analytics and
and sort of the the stuff that was
important over there for that he was in
the the email traffic with with me and
the people I was trying to pitch at
Weight Watchers and it turned out he had
gone to business school not here but I
think Columbia and they had done my case
and so I will just tell you this never
in a million years when I did that case
did I think that it would end up having
so much benefit to me because you're
like this weird quasi celebrity when you
have a Harvard case about about you and
people really do pay attention to that
stuff and so the guy sent me you know
and he said by the way I read your case
I really loved it and so then I had a
buddy and he was really helpful at
getting me some premium placement and
letting the ad run for a few extra days
and stuff like that so you do discover
that sometimes in the strangest places
there will be a connection that you
don't expect there to be on the other
side the other thing I'm doing right now
my real job is my daughter calls it is
I'm doing corporate governance
and I'd be happy to talk at more length
about that or talk about why I chose it
I can I can tell you why in sort of
really short thing I didn't want to have
a full-time job anymore I love working
with people to build something I really
like the challenges of being part of a
corporation and public company
governance is a really interesting field
right now because in some ways people
are running away from it in droves so
it's a growth opportunity and and they
do actually pay you money to do to do
that so you can you can have fun and
make money at the same time be involved
with interesting people and you can
assemble a portfolio of things and still
work from home and drive your kids to
school and do all that other kind of
stuff so it's it's interesting work and
it fits very well with sort of this
phase of my life
and where I'm going I'll tell you again
you know there is no monster.com for
getting job getting bored of director
positions and interestingly more than 70
percent more than 75% of all board of
director positions in in the biggest
companies in America are filled without
the use of a headhunter it's really done
by word of mouth
it's the Governance Committee sits
around and they say who do you know well
I don't know who do you know and they
network out through their friends and so
it is it is very much a situation of
using a network but it's it is a very
odd thing in the sense that first of all
you don't know when these positions come
up they start recruiting for them way
ahead of time you even if you have a
best friend who knows that you're on two
other boards when they're sitting in
that corporate governance committee
meeting and they say who do we know your
name does not pop in their head
immediately as this perfect person so
you have to let your own network know
and so one day last February I decided I
needed to really push my network a
little bit and I sat down and over the
course of about eight hours I wrote one
hundred and fifty something individual
emails to everybody I knew that I knew
well enough who was on a board who was
in a service organization for a board
you know for example an attorney or an
accountant or a recruiter or whatever or
a CEO or a CTO level cxl level person in
a company
saying hey remember here I am I made it
easy here are my board qualifications
here's a URL to my website about me and
board service if you know of anybody
looking for a board member let me know
and you know low and behold one of the
boards I'd now sit on TiVo it just so
happened that you know later that
evening I went to a cocktail party and
there was a venture capitalist that I'd
served on a board with ten years ago and
he's on the tebow board and he's leaving
the tebow board and he said he'd be
perfect for that board I never would
have thought of you think I'd you sent
me that email and then oh by the way
thank God I ran into you at this party
tonight and that's how that process
started so so do not believe so I guess
my my the point of all of that is do not
believe that just because you've been
around for a long time and everybody
knows you and you're 50 something years
old that you don't still have to work at
it and you don't have to do the homework
and you don't have to make it easy for
other people to connect the dots with
and for you because you still you still
have to do the work and I'm still doing
the work so you mentioned the power of
networking and I imagine for someone
like you networking may come very easily
but what are your recommendations for
Shire students that are looking to grow
their network as they leave the GSB well
first of all I don't think networking is
necessarily easy for people I am I'm
definitely definitely a talker you can
probably tell and I like people so for
me it's a little bit easier to walk into
a room and you know have conversations
with people but it isn't it isn't
something that you know every day I'm
just the last the first thing I want to
do when I get up in the morning is go
down to Starbucks and meet everybody
else in the line or something I mean I
do I do
I do recommend that you you know you
don't want to walk in a room and meet
everybody in the room that's not the
point the point is to to come in have a
sense of who the people are have a sense
of what you're trying to accomplish
you only need one good conversation to
lead to other things and for example
it's important again do homework I
recently attended the fortune most
powerful women in business conference
and I
through the list of attendees ahead of
time and I figured out who might I like
to meet from that list and and I looked
at not only the attendees but who are
the friends the people I knew at that
conference that even though we live a
block from each other we may not have an
opportunity to see each other that often
so I had a kind of sense in my head okay
these are the ten people when I go to
this conference of 300 women these are
the ten I'm gonna try to to find my way
to and meet and and talk to I also think
that today a lot of networking occurs in
a way that is not you know that you
don't have to be social I mean you don't
even have to be dressed to do it right
you know you're sitting in your pajamas
and you're on email and you're I mean I
always laugh about this because we do a
lot of board committee meetings and
stuff on the phone and I always think
thank god video conferencing isn't that
in yet because half the time I'm sitting
there in my bathrobe and you know I just
hope because they're East Coast so they
have why don't you have conference calls
at 6:00 in the morning on I do not look
at it 6:00 in the morning
so so I do think that there are also if
you're not a talker person you can build
relationships online you can build
relationships in in in different manners
it doesn't have to be you know the
proverbial cocktail party I think you
can build it around nonprofits you can
build it around ad hoc committees
committees here at the school you can
build it around various forms of social
philanthropy so there are other ways to
go about it and ways that even if you're
not you know super social you can do
those things that the the the main
advice I would give you there is don't
go out looking for for pen pals you know
don't go out looking to collect business
cards to me that the hardest thing is
I'll get I'll get email from someone and
it basically is like hi I've read about
you I'd really like to be your pen pal
can we get together I'm like okay to do
what you know and you have a
conversation and you're sort of done I
think that the best way you get to know
other people in the best way they get to
know you is in the context of
accomplishing something and whether that
is serving on a volunteer committee or
whether that is work
on a project together or whatever it is
if you can figure out something you can
do with someone you want to get to know
better that is a lot better than just
stalking them you know because at the
end of the day that isn't there isn't
gonna be really a lot of value delivered
if you do that switching gears a little
I know that our first year is just read
the Heidi Roizen case and their
organizational behavior class and in in
that case they talked about the
experiment of switching your name from
Heidi to Howard yes we'd love to hear
your reactions to that and what you took
it to take sure not sure sure well like
I say the cases has it has a life of its
own and it's pretty funny and and about
I get about 10 emails a week from
students all across the country who just
emailed me I'm pretty sure just to see
if I respond and so then I do and then
they're surprised and and actually one
time it was pretty funny because this
guy was having this email exchange with
me and he asked me a question or two he
was in class right and they were doing
the case and he was getting answers for
me real-time and raising his hand wow
that is creative I want to hire that guy
but it is it's so the case is funny
because it really does afford this this
you know this like I say this weird you
know little niches of infamy or whatever
it is and I also want to say being the
subject of a case I will tell you this I
do have actual friends that I see that
have nothing to do with work and and and
and and and the point is that cases are
an abstraction of reality because
they're trying to teach you something
and one of the things I find that's
interesting about this case is that it
is controversial and at some places
what's interesting when I teach it at
Harvard I've done it taught it
telephonically at Harvard and it's
controversial because I've decided at
Harvard you get graded on creating
controversy and so they make everything
controversial it's a little less
controversial here but but there is this
this question people have of me all the
time about you know how much do you
really mix your personal and business
life and on the one hand I think it's
really great to mix your personal and
business life because you know I have a
lot of the same I picked people to do
business with in a lot of the same way I
picked friends are they ethical are they
good people are they interesting you
know
and so there is a lot of crossover and I
think in the valley particularly there's
a tremendous amount of crossover but
there are boundaries and it's one of
things you know obviously the case sort
of paints a little bit funnier picture
about that you know bathing my kids
while I'm having a business meeting in
the bathroom and stuff like that yeah
it's a little extreme right relative to
reality I don't do that that often
particularly now that they're 14 and 16
of them they're really weird in fact
they don't even let me in the bathroom
anymore when you know it's so but so the
cases has been really interesting and
I've gotten some really interesting
connections from the case and this this
thing that came up where Frank Flynn who
who taught here for a while actually
also he was at Columbia and he decided
to run an experiment where he changed
the person from Heidi to Howard and then
taught two sections of the same at the
same time of a first-year class and then
he had people go online and rate the how
they felt about Heidi and Howard and the
interesting thing is Heidi and Howard
scored just as well on effectiveness but
not on like how much you would like this
person how much would you want to work
with this person how much would you
trust this person and when he told me
this so he tracked me down I didn't know
him beforehand it was actually very
funny my nephew was in was in at
Columbia at the time and was in his
class and because we have such an
unusual last name he said do you know
how do you raisin and my nephew say I
asked my aunt he said oh I did this
interesting study I'd love to talk to
her about it
and hey I was surprised that there was a
statistically significant difference
between Heidi and Howard and B when he
asked me who do you think is doing the
biasing I thought it was the women and
he said no it's the men and the fact
that I would even think it was the women
you know there's so many levels of
what's wrong with this picture in in a
lot of it and so you know it does it
really does amazed me because I would
have thought in this day and age this is
just not something we would have to
worry about anymore and yet there was
this subtle difference and you know
we're not talking about old middle-aged
white guys we're talking about a group
of students only five years ago you know
so not that dissimilar
yourselves and you know so so my
takeaway from that was gosh it's
disappointing I still don't
I still don't personally feel that bias
I mean I still think in terms of a
gender bias and and maybe it's
interesting that I've picked corporate
governance because in corporate
governance there is a there is a strong
momentum and initiative towards having
more women on board so maybe I've
actually picked a place where my gender
is helpful to getting my foot in the
door once my foots in the door if I'm
only there if I'm only running on a
diversity ticket please don't give me
that job because I'm not gonna do the
job they're not gonna be happy with me
so it's I actually hesitate a little
when someone says well they need to put
a woman on the board and that's why they
want to talk to you but I still take the
meeting because you take the meeting for
whatever reason and once you get there
you can say well is it is are they just
trying to check a box or is it that
they'd love to have a woman because yes
it does check a box but they're really
only looking for someone who's who's
going to contribute an add value and I
think you can really tell that in the
interviews so let's hope that if they
run the heidi howard test again in five
years or some other equivalent case you
know we'll just keep getting better and
better at this point in in our careers i
know many of us are looking for mentors
so I'd love to hear how you've found
mentors and how helpful they've been to
you and your career so I think it again
it goes back to a little bit to that
penpal thing I've tried doing the
Stanford programs where I've mentored
students here and I have to admit I
don't sign up for them anymore just
because I found it really didn't we you
know we can go walk and I can give you
advice and that's sort of it you know
the the the flip side is when you can
find something to coalesce around when
you can can find a you know an alumni
student group where there's an activity
or a conference or something like that
that you can work on together I find
those work really well for me I really
found my mentors in in two places one is
in work where I was doing business with
someone and decided they were a smart
person and I wanted to attach myself to
them so you know if I think about my
mentors people I can Winblad who
I got to know early on and who we were
Hummer Winblad first investment so then
she was on my board Bill Gates who I you
know worked with closely when you know
and competed with way back in the
beginning of the personal computer
revolution and you know got to know him
and and got to do some business with
Microsoft and so got to know him better
other folks that I literally met here
you know Fred Gibbons and trip Hawkins
and people that that actually came and
spoke to the business school now when I
started my company I would get in touch
with them and I ended up doing business
with their companies so that was a lot
of the way I did it the other thing is I
decided to and I strongly recommend this
I decided to get involved in the trade
associations of the org of the of the
industries I was in so early on in the
personal computer industry there was
something called the sulfur Publishers
Association which was kind of funny
because they weren't like there weren't
very many software publishers so it was
kind of funny that we had this this
industry association and in fact the way
I found out about it is we had this this
user of one of our products and she
would call in all the time and and she
was in her I don't know
70s or 80s she was not a young woman and
and personal computer user in 1983-84
when you're in your seventies or
whatever that's really highly unusual
it's not a lot more common now but it
wasn't then and she would always say to
me my nephew Kenny is starting this
group of people like you and she just
kept saying you know my nephew Kenny and
I oh god no this woman oh she she
seriously I mean I'm not kidding she
lived in like a mobile home park in Utah
or something and she was telling me that
her nephew Kenny was starting this
software Club or something I thought
okay fine how are your nephew Kenny call
me and it turned out that it was this
guy Ken washed in Washington DC who
started this thing called the sulfur
Publishers Association and so I got
involved with that and then that grew
and grew and became a very
improvisational the leadership of that I
ran for for the board and I was elected
to the board and I ended up serving on
that board for eight years I was
president for two and then subsequently
I was I did the same thing with the
National Venture Capital Association
rose onto the board and I was actually
elected chairman of that ultimately I
stepped down because I wasn't going to
stay in venture capital and I thought
would be really weird to be chairman of
the National Venture Capital Association
and not be a venture capitalist
so I proactively stepped down from that
position but I got elected the the thing
about a trade association is you know
there are a lot of work and you don't
get paid to do them but the connections
you make and the contacts you make and
your presence in the industry ends up
being so much vaster and greater than
whatever it might be merited by the size
of your company alone so you know tea
maker was this little piddly company
that sort of nobody cared about but yet
I was on the board of the trade
association and I got to testify before
the Senate on the sulfur rental Act I
got to go to Japan and represent the
United States software industry I got to
do all these interesting things and I
got to meet the other leaders of the
software industry who were you know I
was sitting on that board with people
who had much much bigger companies than
I did and those were people who I ended
up getting to know the same thing with
the NBC a I ended up being on the board
with other venture capitalists who had
deal flow right which was really nice
and who had money to invest in my
companies and so I ended up doing
business with those people so I'm a big
proponent of trade associations in spite
of the fact that they are sort of
bureaucratic and and and you know and
you don't get paid to do it and they're
really long hours but I really think
that they benefit you I think the other
thing is it gets your head out of your
own daily business and I know
particularly in Silicon Valley maybe not
so much anymore but back in the Stone
Age is when I was starting a company we
really thought of Washington and
government and the feds and all that as
all those really stupid people on the
other coast that just stay out of our
way and leave us alone and the more I
got involved in trade associations the
more I started to understand the
connection between government and
governmental policy and what actually
happens at my little company and my
ability to create jobs and and things
like you know visas and taxation and and
and how they slice up broadband and how
they how they regulate things really do
impact your little company in ways that
are rather
alarming sometimes and rather wonderful
sometimes if you can figure out how to
be on the right side of that equation so
for me it opened my eyes to a lot of
things that as a small entrepreneur I
would have said oh God who cares what
those people in Washington do anyway
well now I care a lot more about what
those people in Washington do there's a
reason why you know Google and Microsoft
and Cisco and whatever have offices and
employees and all those sitting in
Washington because it really really
really matters so I guess for our last
question what is the best piece of
advice that you would give to MBA
students to make the most out of their
time at the GSB
what a great question um well first of
all you're just in a you're at a great
school I mean and and everybody will
come here and talk and you get you know
when I just look at the roster of people
who are walking through here all the
time it's just remarkable so take
advantage of all that number one number
two each other you know and and it isn't
even just each other in this room or in
the in the years that you have here it's
the alums that came slightly before you
it's the students that'll come slightly
after you it's it's really it's like
being a member of the GSB and an alum of
the GSB is like having that secret
handshake and that's sort of anybody
will answer your email or you know I
mean you really are part of this great
thing that I would recommend you
continue to remain close to and continue
to participate in things here because
they will really really pay back in
terms of the learning the actual
learning experience gosh you know there
are there are classes I wish I had taken
when I was here there were a couple
classes I took that we're really hugely
I took negotiation incredibly important
class to me power and politics Jeff
Pfeffer first class he's a great he's
one of the folks to that I you know keep
in touch with to this day it was
important to take accounting because you
got to know that stuff and I and let's
see what was the other one negotiation
creativity in business Michael race
class was just fantastic so there were a
class a few classes and basic marketing
was another one that that really got me
and I loved him
and boy the list after that I really
can't even remember them and and I
remember sitting in some classes in fact
my thing used to always be oh good lord
the black-scholes you know capital asset
pricing model when in my life am I ever
gonna use this
well now I'm on the board of a public
company and guess what they use that hey
I finally got to use it because when
you're you know looking at enterprise
value versus market cap and and and
you're thinking about M&A you actually
have to have this way of saying well how
are we really valued how our options
valued black Scholes came up in this
whole option pricing thing so I finally
had something useful from that class
only 30-something years later I did have
to look it up again and we're going to
figure out I still can't do it but but
but I would but what I would tell you is
is when you have the opportunity to take
classes that sound interesting to you
just take the ones that sound
interesting to you and I would I would
also have to say that I've done a lot of
hiring in my in my years and I can't say
that I've ever looked at someone's
transcript or their GPA or anything like
that it's about what did you do when you
were here what did you take away what
kind of groups and clubs did you involve
yourself with that is the stuff that is
much more important as an employer than
than GPA and I'm sure there are
organizations that look at grades I've
never been one of them and in fact there
have been some studies that argue that
there's a reverse there's a inverse
correlation between your GPA and your
ability to actually work at like an
entrepreneurial company so all you low
achievers there's hope there's hope
so now we're gonna open it up to the
audience and we have two microphones
that'll be going around so if you'll
just raise your hand and they'll come
find you
hi um can you talk a little bit about
how you manage your email did you get I
do it constantly that's that's a good
question I mean I I'm a very active
email user and I I'm you know and I'm
always wired I have it on all the time
and in fact one of the things I'm trying
to do is have the discipline to not look
at it all the time because it is very
addictive and I just came from I was I'm
on the board of I'm on the board of the
yellow pages of Canada which is actually
I know you guys are probably laughing
out oh my god why does she do that
um 1.6 billion a year in revenue 900
million EBIT das 700 million free cash
flow last year
they do business with 46 percent of all
businesses in Canada and 250 million of
that revenue was online and they had
nine million uniques on their website
which by the way is Canada doesn't
really have that many people can ask
what do they have 20 something million
30 million yes over here 30 thank you I
know I was thinking god I'm on the board
of a Canadian company I don't know who
the Prime Minister is if they have one
of those I can't name all the
Providence's provinces and territories
and I don't even know how many people
they have but I know is about the size
of California so I figure okay but but
anyway so so the reason I joined that
board is I thought what an interesting
challenge this company this company
mints money right you know I mean that's
more money than I ever saw in any of the
venture deals I ever did and yet they
have this transformational thing but the
point being is I'm fitting in this board
meeting em and my iPhone is sitting
there and it's like every time it's like
so tempting to look at it right
especially when like audit committees
going on because I hate it and you have
to just turn it over or put it away or
you know step away from it so email is
you know it's a great boon and it's and
it's a terrible thing as well and I find
you know quick answers real efficiency I
try I am one of those people that I
empty my in basket I'm not one of those
people that keeps the sedimentary layer
of email that I don't want to deal with
in my in basket and I try to just
process it and deal with it and you have
to get really good at saying know about
things and
have to be really efficient with how you
do it the thing I'm I'm challenged with
frankly right now is sorry I did Twitter
for a while I I never tweeted but I went
and I followed people and then I thought
oh this is just I'm not doing this I
couldn't find value in it not saying
there isn't value for certain people and
certain things but for me I didn't find
it Facebook just keeping up on Facebook
is just unbelievably hard now part of it
is my daughter says I'm a facebook
she didn't actually use that word but
but because I have like 3,000 friends on
Facebook and and I did that because I
have a consumer product right and so I
want to be friends with everybody but
now you know I get on Facebook and it's
like you have 67 friend requests today
and you know you don't know these people
but now the problem is I have so many
people that you'll come on it says you
have 47 friends in common and then I'll
look at the 47 people I don't really
know any of it I'm working on that I'm
working on that LinkedIn a little bit
better because a little more business
focus but but I find now when you say
manage email it isn't just email right
it's Facebook and it's LinkedIn and it's
Twitter and it's and it's you know
wherever you happen have presence and
are trying to manage your presence and
so I definitely have have there are
things I've sort of opted out of like
being part of the whole you know deeply
I'm not living a lot of my social life
online right I don't because I have an
organized Facebook properly to really
say okay who's the core group I do spy
on my children on Facebook which they
know hey they friended me it's not you
know it's okay and they unfriend me
that's gonna be the problem but I keep
track of them online which I think it's
kind of interesting but other than that
yeah I don't know it's hard emails hard
but I couldn't live without it
a couple weeks ago I was having some
work done on my house and they were
gonna shut my water off for five hours
and then they had to shut my my power
down for some some time and I said I'd
rather live without water some without
connectivity you know I can manage
around water but the connectivity I'm
just gonna go to Starbucks for five
hours no actually actually the Dutch
juice because it's free the excuse has
free wireless where Starbucks you have
to pay or the case spoke about
consistency and performance as the two
main elements of maintaining or having a
good Network could you speak to how you
actually define that and if those really
are the two key very consistent very
consistent good I'm glad no consistency
and and believe me I think about this as
a parent a lot is you know if one time
you say yes and another time you say no
and there's just randomness to it people
don't know what to expect from you and I
think that that this goes with being
genuine consistency is if you know you
ask me something and I'm I have a
consistent set of rules I apply then you
know what you're gonna get from me and I
think that that helps in building of
relationships people know if they ask me
to do something I'm either gonna do it
or I'm gonna tell them I'm not gonna do
it I'm not gonna back burner it and you
know and kind of hem and haw and you
know and and and like this person who
asked me to endorse them I emailed them
back and I said you know what I really
can't do that I'm sure you were great
but I only really do this for people
that I had a direct report you know a
direct relationship with where I could
really say something specific and if not
I just don't think it's valuable to have
an endorsement out there so good luck
but you know but I can't do it for you
so I think consistency it just it makes
your life a lot easier it makes you a
known quantity to people and I think it
helps build your reputation as you know
do what you say you're gonna do
performance to me goes hand in hand with
that right if if you're a person who
constantly drops the ball and doesn't
deliver then again it's gonna hurt your
reputation and for me there are times I
can't perform there are times I just
have to say you know what I have my
priorities and I think this is something
that particularly recently has become
very important to me which is have a
really firm idea in your head of what
your priorities are right and and if
something because it's very easy
particularly when you don't have a day
job to get sucked into whoever is asking
for the most and whoever wants you to do
something and all of a sudden you find
out that you're really busy doing that
and you're falling down on the things
that are that are important to you
because they're not screaming as loud
particularly when you have teenagers
believe me they don't always ask to be
like supervised so you have to have time
for those things taking care of yourself
is another one if you don't make it a
priority it ain't gonna happen and so
I've tried to do that so performance to
me is a matter you know consistency and
performance go so much hand-in-hand and
letting people know if you're going to
do something do it if you're not gonna
do something be clear that you're not
going to do it if you don't have the
timeframe if you can only give to a
certain level of whatever you gonna do
if you're only gonna participate in in
something to a certain level be really
clear about that because the worst thing
to do is is the old overcommit and
under-deliver and I'd rather under
commit and over deliver so I think there
is a constant you know I tell you an
audit of your own activities is also
really important I did this thing a
couple months ago where I just looked at
my calendar and I said how am i spending
my time and I added it all up and said
okay what does this tell me about about
me and my tendency is I'm a responder if
somebody you know I've used this line
before if a total stranger called me up
and said could you pick me up at SFO and
a half an hour I'd really debate that I
probably ought to go do that and so I'm
bad about when people ask me for things
I have a hard time saying no and I think
sometimes you have to develop no muscles
you know you have to be able to say you
know what I'm not gonna do that it's not
that it isn't a worthy cause
right but you have to set some
boundaries and and you know we going to
use a Bill Gates example one of my
boundaries is I never forward requests
for philanthropy to bill right I don't
care who it is or how worthy they are or
Jeff Raikes who I know was a view from
the top speaker here and and is a good
friend of mine and runs the Gates
Foundation I just have a rule I don't
care how good you are you know what
Gates Foundation org they have a whole
thing about their priorities and their
initiatives and how to submit and you
should do that and if I had my own
charity
I wouldn't ask Bill or Jeff for money
because when if you don't put boundaries
like that then it becomes a slippery
slope and all of a sudden it's like you
become the intermediary having to make
these evaluative decisions I don't want
to be there and so sometimes you put
these boxes around things and say that's
this is how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
audit my time I'm gonna think about who
you know the flip side this is if if all
you're doing is reacting and you're just
spending time with the people who want
to spend time with you you might be
missing out on the people that you
really want or need to spend time with
and so another thing that I'm thinking
about a lot recently is who are those
friends who really mean something to me
and spend time with those friends which
means that you know there's only 24
hours in a day you got to turn off some
other things in order to be open to new
experiences in order to be open to
physical exercise in order to be open to
having the time to spend with with
people that that are meaningful to you
that comes from somewhere else and you
have to have the ability to turn those
other things off it's a constant battle
and a constant adjustment
thanks for being here sure I had a
question for you could you talk a little
bit about skinny songs what inspired you
to start it and what are you trying to
achieve sure you know it's really funny
at this Yellowpages board meeting I was
talking about buying Google AdWords you
know this is the funnies like you never
think in a million years well because I
was a sole proprietor and I did this
weight loss thing and I went on Google
AdWords and I was buying AdWords and I
learned some really interesting things
about buying AdWords that are now really
useful to me sitting on the board of
this multi-billion dollar company but I
brought this thing up in the board
meeting about you know when you buy the
words weight loss for example the words
weight loss are so expensive on a cost
per click basis that you know there it
was like ten dollars to buy the word
weight loss weight loss as a search term
and my product only sells for $9.99 so
trust me there is no business model that
makes that an effective strategy and
then I decided I was going to buy all
the names of all my songs erroneously
thinking that people would hear a song
and want to go look it up well one of
the songs has the word hottie in it let
me tell you I bought the keyword hottie
I got a ton of traffic on my site none
of them were my target audience and so I
learned some really interesting things
about buying AdWords and what happens
and search engine you know marketing I
was really interesting but you know life
story short really really simple I
wasn't taking care of myself I gained a
lot of weight two and a half three years
ago I was 40 pounds more than I am right
now and I was looking for motivation to
to lose weight and I was I've always
been a person who loves listening to
music and you know chick empowerment
songs and I was looking for that kind of
stuff online and and I went on iTunes
and I looked around and there was
meditation for weight loss there were a
lot of podcasts about weight loss there
but there weren't any songs like you
know that the equivalent of Gloria
Gaynor's I Will Survive right you break
up with a guy and you listen that song
over and over and over and over again
and you're like yeah and I wanted the I
will survive without eating the plate of
chocolate chocolate chip cookies they're
gonna have it the meeting today and so
that was why I did it I didn't know
where it would take me but I'll tell you
what I learned
from this first of all don't go in the
music business it's not a very good
place to make money the creative process
was super fun though and I ended up
getting to work with some just amazing
people and I talked this one guy David
Malloy into doing that with me and the
first time I talked to him he said okay
so you live in Silicon Valley or venture
capitalist I don't even know what that
is
he's Reba McEntire's producer he's
Julianne Howe or Hough how are you say
your last name he's her producer he's
got 40 number-one hits he's got five
Grammy nominations he's big dog right
he's like a go-to man in Nashville he
says I don't even know what a venture
capitalist is you've never written a
song in your life you don't play an
instrument and you want to write music
for fat chicks no I want to write music
that inspires women to to achieve their
weight loss and fitness goals then he
goes on I don't know that's pretty weird
but send me the sámi they'll send me the
lyrics so I sent him lyrics and the next
day called me and he said I don't know I
still don't get her by took it home I
show it to my wife and she said this is
what women talk about all day long so so
he agreed to do one song with me one
song and by the end of it he he had done
he had co-written seven of the songs he
produced six of them for me
and he told me at the end of the project
it was the most fun he's ever had on any
project because when when he is dealing
with Reba McEntire Kenny Rogers or you
know any of these big-name people they
come in and they really have a very
strong idea me I came in with my lyrics
and I said I want this to sound like
Carrie Underwood or Rascal Flatts or
pink or the black-eyed peas and that's
all I know
here
and and and that's literally what I did
and then he you know he said to me you
know you write poetry we need lyrics and
I said well what's the difference he
said well you know you tend to write I'm
gonna do something I do it I did it and
lyrics are I do it I do it I do it
because people want to sing along and
they don't want to know like what am I
in the beginning of the song I'm in the
middle and I'm and they do you know it
so he would shorten everything and then
he would send me mp3s where he was
strumming on the guitar just singing and
and wherever my words didn't fit he'd go
dah dah dah dah dah and then he'd say me
now you have to rewrite it and then I
would have to rewrite it but we would
have these huge fights about like one
word because to me I was champion of the
lyrics I said if the lyrics I'm all
about the lyrics I'm all about music
that sounds as good as pop radio because
if it didn't you wouldn't listen to it
and then these these lyrics have to be
meaningful and and you can't you can't
change my lyrics so I had a head of one
funny thing he was out of town and he
left his it was the laughing and I was
desperately waiting for it and it was
the only song in which I mentioned dress
sizes and he was out of town I'm waiting
waiting when his last song it comes in
on a Friday night his his his guy that
his co-writer and I fire it up and
listen to it and they had changed the
dress size from 16 to 17 because the
male producer thought 17 was a prettier
sounding number I'm like there is no
dress sizes that's why you guys can't
change the lyrics so and it going to do
it all over again so the coolest thing
what I'll say about that is is there
there are two great things one great
thing is you cannot promote a
weight-loss product and be overweight so
I had to lose weight because I was going
to go on I've been on the Martha Stewart
Show and I've been on CNN and I've been
on CNBC and I've been on Donny Deutsch
and I did a bunch of television and you
cannot hold up a product and say well it
didn't actually work for me but I hope
you will like it so first of all it's
been really helpful and I've had you
know I've lost weight and and and
exercise and you know I'm happy with
with all that and promoting a product
really helped I mean it really does help
the other thing is well three things
second things I got to do this amazing
creative process and learn about
songwriting and the greatest compliment
David Molloy paid me at the end of it as
he said have you ever thought of writing
for other for not for fat chicks yeah he
said you'd be a great lyricist he goes
you know I've worked with a lot of
lyricists and you'd be a great lyricist
I'm like thank you I mean there's no
money in it but but I was very pleased
that somebody who's you know that big
dude would actually want to work with me
on things other than that so the
creative process was great and and then
the final thing is I get fan mail every
once in a while from someone who says
your music helped change my life and
that's really cool when you get
something from someone who says I was
really struggling and then I got your CD
and it just was the thing that helped me
and it put my hat I got one from a woman
a couple of weeks ago she lost 200
pounds and she said when she got to
about 140 she just couldn't get anywhere
I couldn't get anywhere and then
somebody gave her my CD and it really
helped her and so that guy stuff is just
I mean that just makes your day right
when you get something like that so I'm
really glad I did it it's it's
profitable now that's because we pay the
CEO no money and I just enough CDs to
pay all the expenses of the business and
keep it up and running and you know I'm
really proud of it and I'm really glad I
did it
am I gonna do any more probably not but
but it was it's really fun really
different and it really has taught me a
lot about being a small business because
I'm I'm on I'm iTunes I'm on Amazon I'm
an Amazon affiliate associate I use
fulfillment by Amazon I've bought Google
Adwords and so in a funny way having
this little inky dinky business made me
go do a bunch of stuff that's really
valuable to know sitting at the other
end of the spectrum now on on the board
of the yellow pages I can really relate
to the small business owner because I
had to do a lot of that stuff myself
question so in the case they talked a
little bit about your waiting way to
connect with people and as you mentioned
with the Women's Conference and out of
300 people you saw 10 at a party what
does your mind you meet that person the
first time I mean is it I stalked you on
the Internet
here's what I found it and I think
that's the that you're bringing up the
really interesting question between
being this sort of like stalker Otzi
person who's you know who's in there
with an agenda versus just going and
wanting to meet interesting people right
and I think you know sometimes you know
obviously if you walk into a room and
you know that the VP of Marketing for
coca-cola is there and that Tebow has
this amazing stuff about coca-cola add
efficacy that you'd like the VP of
Marketing to know about maybe you're
gonna go find that person on the other
end you might just say wow here's a
person I've always want you know
recently there was a person who wanted
me to meet with Sherry Lansing about
something and I've always wanted to meet
cherry Lansing so of course I took the
meeting even if I wasn't that interested
in the thing necessarily well it wasn't
that I wasn't interested but but there
was a big piece of the draw was I was
gonna get to meet Sherry Lansing and she
would be a person I respect a lot and
she's you know done a tremendous amount
in film and with cancer awareness and
research and so I just wanted to meet
her so I don't know what what goes on in
your mind it isn't so much that I have
an agenda and I'm trying to - usually it
isn't that I have an agenda usually it's
I love knowing interesting people and I
generally find if you get to know other
interesting people interesting things
happen in your life and so I don't know
I don't I don't feel like it's that
methodical I will say this and and this
is one of those if you if you really
want to know how to succeed in the when
you get out of Business School my
takeaway from my last year and I'll
close on this is homework never stops
you always have to do homework and the
more you just accept that and say I
don't care how big and powerful and
important you get at the end of the day
if you also do a little homework and
I've learned this in going for board
interviews no matter how much I'm a
great fit and my background looks great
or they read my case in business school
so they think I'm
if you walk in and you haven't read the
annual report combed the website no in
the background that people know what
school everybody went to know what their
hobbies you know go learn about the
people you're meeting with and don't
just presume that your natural talent
and grace and wonderfulness is going to
carry you through an interview because
what I've learned and now that I'm on a
board you know my goal on these boards I
serve on is I want the CEO at the end of
the year when he looks around and says
who contributed the most to this company
from the board I want to be that person
right I don't want to just be there and
be the token girl on the board or that
you know whatever I want to go in there
and I want to do such an awesome job
because I want to do boards for the next
20 years or whatever and when that CEO
gets called I want him to you know say
oh my god she's fantastic
and that takes homework and believe me
reading reading SEC filings is not that
fun but it's part of the homework right
and and you know and and so homework
that's all I'll close with that is I'm
sorry to tell you this but homework
never ends but thanks to the internet
you can at least do it at home in your
pajamas